imagine this I'm in Tanzania and I am
about to enter the airport in dar Salam
I have a large suitcase with elephant
tusks inside trying to put all the bags
in together to try to mask and the bags
go through and then he says the worst
thing an airport official could possibly
say in a moment like that
he says open that bag I opened the bag
and there's really no getting around it
I lift the tusks out and all hell breaks
loose so what I haven't told you is that
these elephant tusks were fake I had
them made by a taxidermist in New Jersey
in George Dante and he's the taxidermist
for the American Museum of Natural
History and I went to him and I said
George I need perfect elephant tusks and
inside I want to put the satellite base
GPS system I'm going to take these tusks
over to Africa and I'm going to use them
in the black market
he said I've never done anything like
this and he said Brian let me get this
straight
are you telling me you could get killed
if they don't believe that these are
real I said it's going to be very
important George takes a couple of
months he has made these perfect tusks
they have the right feel as the right
look he has the right density and the
right sound you know if you cut a tusk
in half like cutting a tree there are
rings inside he's painted those
hand-painted he's painted all the little
cracks along the tusk it was
extraordinary the elephants are under
siege and this isn't just a animal
problem the Rangers on the ground
protecting these elephants are being
killed and the ivory is being used to
fund terrorist organizations operating
in Africa so this is a human problem as
well as an animal
it's one we have to do better on so I'm
telling the Tanzanian Airport official
that these are fake that I've had them
made the numb it's part of a study I'm
doing and he starts to believe me and
then behind him people start pointing at
the x-ray machine and say no it's not
ivory he's looking at the electronics
inside the tusks he says that's not an
elephant tusks that's a bomb and then it
was about as bad as it's it's ever
gotten for me in terms of being gone on
this a as a criminal the police grabbed
me and took me to an interrogation room
and then things went from kind of
amusing won't this make a good story to
okay this is real the next morning all
the officials coming after five or six
hours because they're mostly convinced
they're convinced enough to let me go
it's put it that way there were some
people who never stopped believing ours
that was real life after everything was
over after they said okay we're free to
go many of the officials who arrested me
came to the airport to say goodbye
they've all become Facebook friends
I don't get in too much trouble but
occasionally I get in a lot of trouble
[Music]
you
[Music]